what is plasma what is the role of
plasma and nuclear fusion
so plasma is a phase of matter or state
of matter so
unfortunately our schools don't it's
like I'm not sure why this is the case
but all all children learn the three
phases of matter right so and what does
this mean so we'll take like Waters an
example so if you if it's cold it's ice
it's in a solid phase right and then if
you heat it up the temp it's the
temperature that typically depends sets
the phase although it's not it's not
only temperature so you heat it up and
you go to a liquid and obviously it
changes its physical properties because
it can you can pour it and so forth
right and then if you heat this up
enough it turns into a gas and a gas
behaves differently because there's a
very Sudden Change in the density
actually that's what's happening so it
changes by about a factor of ten
thousand in density from the from the
liquid phase into when you make it into
steam at atmospheric pressure all very
good except the problem is they forgot
like what happens if you just keep
elevating the temperature you don't want
to give kids ideas they're going to
start experimenting and they're going to
start heating up the gas it's good to
start doing anyway so you
um it turns out that once you get above
it's approximately five or ten thousand
degrees Celsius then you hit a new phase
of matter and actually that's the phase
of matter that is for all pretty much
all the temperatures that are above that
as well too
um and so what does that mean so it
actually changes so it's a different
state of matter and the reason that it
becomes a different state of matter is
that it's hot enough that what happens
is that the atoms that make up remember
go back to Feynman right everything's
made up of these individual things these
atoms but atoms can actually themselves
be
um which are which are made of nuclei
which contain the positive particles and
the neutrons and then the electrons
which are very very light very much less
mass than than the nucleus and that
surround this this is what makes up an
atom so a plasma is what happens when
you start pulling away enough of those
electrons that they're free from the ion
so almost all the atoms that make up us
up and this water and all that the
electrons are in tightly bound States
and basically they're extremely stable
once you're about five thousand or ten
thousand degrees you start pulling off
the electrons and what this means is
that now the medium that is there its
constituent particles have mostly have
net charge on them
so why does that matter it's because now
this means that the particles can
interact but through their electric
charge in some sense they were when it
was in the atom as well too but now that
they're free particles this means that
they start it fundamentally changes the
behavior it doesn't behave like a gas it
doesn't behave like a solid or a liquid
I mean he's like a plasma right and so
why is this why is it disappointing that
we don't speak about this it's because
99 of the universe is in the plasma
State it's called Stars
and in fact our own Sun at the center of
the sun is what clearly a plasma but
actually the surface of the sun which is
around 5500 Celsius is also a plasma
because it's hot enough that is that in
fact the things that you see sometimes
you see these pictures from the surface
of the Sun amazing like Satellite
photographs of like those big arms of
things and of light coming off of the
surface of the Sun and solar flares
those are plasmas what are some
interesting ways that this forced data
matter is different than gas
let's go to how a gas works right so the
reason a gap and it goes back to
fireman's Brilliance and saying that
this is the most important concept the
reason actually solid liquid and gas
phases work is because the the nature of
the interaction between the atoms
changes and so in a gas you can think of
this as being this room and the things
although you can't see them is that the
molecules are
flying around but then with some
frequency they basically bounce into
each other and when they bounce into
each other they exchange momentum and
energy around on this
and so it turns out that the probability
and the distances and the scattering of
those of what they do it's it's those
interactions that set the uh about how a
gas behaves so what do you mean by this
well so for example if I take a a an
imaginary test particle of some kind
like I spray something into the air
that's got a particular color in fact
you can do it in liquids as well too
like how it gradually will disperse away
from you this is this is fundamentally
set because of the way that those
particles are bouncing into the
probabilities of those political bonds
the rate that they go at and the
distance that they go out and so forth
so this was figured out by Einstein and
others at the beginning of the Browning
motion all these kinds of things these
are these were set um up at the
beginning of the last century and was
really like this great Revelation wow
this is why matter behaves the way that
it does like wow
um
um so but it's really like and also in
liquids and in solids like what really
matters is is is is is how you're
interacting with your nearest neighbor
so you think about that one the gas
particles are basically going around
until the until they actually hit into
each other though they don't really
exchange information and it's the same
in a liquid you're kind of beside each
other but you can kind of move around in
a solid you're literally like stuck
beside your neighbor you can't move like
yeah
plasmas are are weird in the sense is
that they're it's not like that so it is
because the particles have electric
charge this means that they can push
against each other without actually
being in close proximity to each other
it's not that's not an infinitely true
statement which because again it's a
little bit more technical but basically
this means that you can start having
action or exchange of information at a
distance
and that's in fact the definition of a
plasma that it says these have a
technical name is called a coulomb
collisions it just means that it's
dictated by this Force which is being
pushed between the charged particles is
that the definition of a plasma is a is
a medium in which the collective
behavior is dominated by these
collisions at a distance
so you can imagine then this starts to
to give you some Strange Behaviors
um uh which I could I could quickly talk
about like for example one of the most
counter-intuitive ones is as plasmas get
more hot as they get higher in
temperature then the collisions happen
less frequently
it's like like what that doesn't make
any sense when particles go faster you
think they would Collide more often
but because the particles are
interacting through interacting through
their electric field when they're going
faster they actually spend less time in
the influential field of each other and
so they talk to each other Less in an
energy and momentum exchange point of
view it's just just one of the count one
of the counter-intuitive aspects of
plasmas which is probably very uh
relevant for nuclear fusion yes exactly